in the film it shows you guys having a
fun time driving across country and and
and living this fun life selling your
you know CDs at bars what would you tell
two women in a similar situation because
I'm sure there were times when it wasn't
this one
Oh what advice how do you we're taking a
trip like that Oh anytime that you throw
yourself out there in a risky situation
you're you're only learning and you're
only gaining and like Anika says in the
beginning of the movie it's easy to say
no it's hard to say yes it's a challenge
so you know take the chance take the
risk that's what I would say to anyone
you only grow as a person
and then how did you get ron jeremy
Rick's rocket ships enough sure so we
got to Hollywood you know we made we did
some concerts we made the video and we
decided to do in Hollywood we had done
across all the kind across the country
Network and talk about our project that
we were excited about talk about our
band you know sell our CDs share our
music and I did kind of have both a very
outgoing I'd like to have fun and and
we're just we're excited about our arts
and wanted to share it so we you know
Hollywood's a small town is what you
find out
so we met ron jeremy in a bar and he was
enamored by an acai who sometimes comes
across i like to say as a modern Zsa Zsa
Gabor and so and and we just said hey
Ron you be in our music video you know
thinking it was a shot in the dark and
what do you know a week later he's a
calls and I'm like oh my god Ron Jeremy
called me
is it yes so you're planning this music
video okay yeah so what are the dates oh
I'll put it down when I was like wow
yeah so he was in our music video for
free and then um we can we met rod and
we would socialize with him once in a
while and it sort of gets you access to
the rest of the Sunset Strip world and
we met Steven Adler's brother Jaime and
actually went on tour with Steven
Tyler's band so that we we did that last
summer we went on tour across the
country with his band called Adler's
appetite and chips enough with his bass
player so um so we got snow Steven and
he he also was in the movie for free
thank you guys and then we just started
like networking and going out to any
types of music seminars as well or trade
shows like for instance there's a really
famous one here in Los Angeles called
neom and Rikki Rockett has a drum
company and he is there and selling and
promoting his drums so I just went up to
Mum was like you know I'm making a
documentary and I think that you would
have a really relevant perspective
because you came from Pennsylvania like
we did and would you be interested in
interviewing for it you see this isn't a
normal fan I said okay email me so we
emailed him and he was willing to do it
and I also did it for free so it's just
like if you asked you know there's the
chance you may receive if you don't ask
you never know
you